tired of living fragt wenn du könntest
würdest du die zeit zurückdrehen und nie
mit youtube anfangs s kids und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem reallife video aus
meinem bett schlafe ich hier also direkt
hier unten auf dem boden dicke matratze
ich bin seit drei wochen hier auf einer
matratze auf dem boden finde ich ehrlich
gesagt schreibt meine kommentare wir so
schlaff habt ihr im bett oder straße und
verschafft ihr auch noch matratze auf
dem boden die brauche ich gesagt gar
kein bett gestellt ich finde es
irgendwie schwierig es ist einerseits
bisschen nicht asozial aber so ein
bisschen aber es hat irgendwie seine
eigenen flair hier auf dem boden zu
schlafen ja ich habe unter dem hashtag
question qsc um fragen gebeten es ist
gerade zwei uhr 10 an einer sonntag
macht also danach zwischen sonntag und
montag und hier ist mein wunderbares
tieren die in new york traf hallo ich
bin scharf
ok bevor jetzt noch lustigere will ich
sagen wir legen erstmal los mit diesen
fragen fragt was machst du gerade
grinsen das war
ich sitze gerade in meinem bett habe ich
eine hose an niemand weiß es auf jeden
fall ja ich auf meiner matratze ist kein
bett nicht beantworte fragen mehr
gestellt hat macht zum 2 übrigens
richtig cool dass so viele fragen nachts
um zwei noch zusammen kam
dafür gibt es ein dickes plus 100 für
euch edwin lp fragt wohin geht sehr
spontan urlaub mitten macht dazu die
geschichte ich hatte gestern am samstag
als max kam auf twitter gepostet wo man
am besten nach flügen sucht wenn man nur
den zielort angeben will also uns ging
es darum dass wir so eine schnapsidee
hatten einfach zum flughafen zu fahren
einfach den günstigsten flug irgendwohin
zu nehmen also für meinen geburtstag
weil irgendwas krasses machen wollten
haben wir aber am ende nicht gemacht wie
wien rp deswegen ist dieser spontan
urlaub irgendwo hin gegangen doch der
ging an die spree in den monbijoupark in
berlin da habe ich meinen 18 gefeiert
der 28 ich bin 20 geworden
heutigen tag an diesem sonntag im
vierten zehn bin ich 20 geworden und die
nacht vom samstag auf den sonntag also
im dritten auf den vierten zehnten
geburtstags nach habe ich mindestens 0
uhr da im monbijoupark verbracht da bin
ich 20 geworden teilt auf laping fragt
wenn du könntest würdest du die zeit
zurückdrehen und nie mit youtube
anfangen bzw würdest du dich auf zeigen
also da geht es darum ob ich mich zeigen
würde oder ob ich mit youtube anfangen
würde und ehrlich gesagt ich will auf
jeden fall noch mal mit youtube anfangen
ich glaube mit youtube anzufangen war
mit panischen die beste idee die ich
vielleicht in meinem leben hatte was
wirklich die beste idee jeden fall einer
der besten ideen das macht mir wirklich
viel spaß jeden tag das feedback von
euch zu bekommen und auch wenn es nicht
manchmal schlaf kostet bin auch immer
manchmal keinen bock hat ein video auf
zudem so ist es für mich auch oft
richtig oft aber manchmal macht einfach
kein wochen wieder aufzunehmen aber man
setzt sich halt trotzdem hin und
motiviert sich damit die leute was haben
sich anschauen zu können als es kostet
manchmal ein bisschen anstrengungen
bisschen schlaf aber trotzdem es war
echt eine richtig gute idee von mir
dieses projekt zu starten und ich würde
auf jeden fall noch mit youtube anfangen
wenn ich die gelegenheit hätte würde ich
mich noch mal zeigen ich glaube ja also
ich hab kein problem damit in der
öffentlichkeit angesprochen zu werden
wenn doch nicht schüchtern nicht wenig
verlegen ich freue mich immer zuschauer
zu treffen ich habe eher den eindruck
dass sich manche zuschauer nicht trauen
nicht anzusprechen zum beispiel letztens
wieder in berlin nirgendwo später den
kiosk der nachts noch lange offen hat
war so ein typ so fällt so 13 14 hatte
sich der gemeine marke gekauft oder so
hätten wir im moment auch aus gekauft er
guckt mich so an so und ich gucke zurück
ich hatte irgendwie den einem christi
erkannt hatte zahle ich übrigens schon
öfters in berlin aber die leute sprechen
also leute wenn ihr mich seht macht euch
keine sorgen ich bin nicht böse ich
greife niemand an ihr könnt ruhig trau
mich anzusprechen
das ist kein ding
oder eine frage noch jp ross frage
machst du ein praktikum im moment und
willst irgendwann mal eine familie groß
ziehen noch ein praktikum momentan bei
einem internet unternehmen an der
torstraße
ich weiß nicht ob ich sagen soll welches
das ist ich habe eigentlich schon mal
eingeblendet also in der büro tour stets
drin für alle die es wissen wollen euch
das video an davis eingeblendet wenn ich
mal von mir groß ziehen
ja aber ich hab' ich gesagt riesen
respekt davor
selbst kinder groß zu ziehen weil man
einfach so viel weiß nicht falsch machen
kann man zieht die kinder eigentlich
manchmal zieht sie groß man formt die
kinder kindern sind in so einem jungen
alter und man sieht sehr groß von 0 bis
18 20 21 was auch immer noch länger
auch wenn sie ausziehen man formt diese
menschen eigentlich sowie klumpen leben
wenn ihr diese meter verfolgen wie
nachvollziehen könnt man formt sie und
man kann halt auch viel falsch machen
und davor habe ich respekt also ich
möchte auf jeden fall nichts falsch
machen der erziehung ich will eine
familie gründen aber ich hab halt auch
keine lustige kinder fall stolz ihn
steht ihr was ich meine
dafür habe ich auf jeden fall respekt
und auch eine person zu heiraten das
finde ich auch richtig krasse ideen okay
doch letzte frage von südfriedhof welche
superkraft würdest du nehmen wenn du
eine auswählen könnte man lieber zu tue
ich würde auf jeden fall fliegen und
fliegen oder teleportieren fliegen aber
dann richtig schnell fliegen können da
könnte ich zum beispiel jetzt sagen
kein bock auf berlin ich gehe nach
indien in welchem zwei drei stunden
irgendwie indien könnte aber so superman
will sich so durch die gegend fliegen
die crew war das denn aber leute bevor
der abriss und weiter zur neige geht und
die kamera fällt auf mit aufzunehmen
danke fürs zuschauen las gerne ein
leichter wir sehen uns morgen wieder mit
der neuen folge gaming
es war hart rein